on est en route vers les monts groulx un
massif situé à environ 1h30 au nord de
manic-5 spa porte à côté maintenant même
si ça a l'air bien tranquille chaque
hiver ça brasse tremont group
[Musique]
quand on vient ici on cherche
oui l'aventuré l'immensité mais on
cherche aussi la quiétude
les gens qui arrivent jabbeke mariage
sur gotfrag 16 heures de route
où
j'en viens de pau ainsi pouvoir déposer
maternelle que l'on aime la montagne
c'est sûr que tu peux pas la garder
jusqu'au vous allez rencontrer ces deux
hommes qui s'entendent pas vraiment sur
l'avenir de la montée mais on va
commencer par vous raconter l'histoire
récente des monts groulx
[Musique]
au début des années 2000 le gouvernement
du québec a décrété qu'une partie du
massif des monts groulx un territoire
trois fois grand comme l'île de montréal
allait devenir une aire protégée
on l'a appelée la réserve de
biodiversité woippy scop
l'objectif protéger ce territoire
exceptionnel des industries des mines et
de la forêt pour limiter les
conséquences des activités humaines
on a aussi interdit la pratique de la
motoneige dans les zones alpines ont
jugé que ces zones là était trop fragile
et qu'elle abritait des espèces rares à
protéger les membres où on protège le
portage de spécial c'est calpine on
protège un peu le le caribou on partage
des lieux pratiquer des sports de plein
air
c'est vraiment un endroit qui au lieu
d'être protégé mais québec a finalement
changé sa réglementation les motoneiges
font maintenant partie du paysage
et ça ça ne fait pas que des heureux
depuis cinq ans j'ai bientôt mon groupe
attendre
vivant forêts en fête et pas dans le
stress de faire les choses vite mais de
toujours quelque chose à faire
ça arrive que évidemment il ya des temps
à mort puis le j'en profite pour me
poser à garda matelly qui l'a vite de
mon poids labour c'est de mon poste
préféré
je me considère vraiment à pas comme une
ennemie
il ya comme un image mythique de
l'ermite qui le vieux bonhomme qui avec
son eau douce que dès que quelqu'un qui
arrive son terrain il ya autre qui parle
au contraire qu'un que des gens qui
arrivent je compte aller rencontrer une
vie solitaire parce que je lui seul la
forêt mais je rencontre quand même assez
de deux personnes deux randonneurs qui
parle aussi l'été puis même l'hiver
guy boudreau et guides aventure pour
gagner sa vie il fait découvrir les
membres ou randonneurs son combat depuis
qu exane et c'est de faire sortir les
motoneiges de la réserve de biodiversité
[Musique]
une des caractéristiques que les gens
retrouvent ici le fait qu'ils ont le
sentiment d'être les premiers à venir de
mon loup
on est comme petit face à toute seule
cette immensité là c'est le grand nord
en miniature
en est à un tournant majeur de l'avenir
des moqueries présentement le
développement des monts groulx dans sa
dimension touristique la façon que c'est
parti c'est chaotique
c'est un art chic
cette édition qui vont être plus
présentement vont influencer ce que les
magouilles dans dix quinze vingt ans
depuis c'est un call le territoire qui
étaient octroyés aux motoneiges ne cesse
de grandir
alors on n'est pas dans la bonne
direction pour préserver l'homme du
monde
aralar qui vient ici cherche la nature
sauvage la quiétude laventure des beaux
paysages y arrivant au démon coup et
émerveillée par une multitude de
montagne comme on a derrière un moment
donné mais le soin au loin on entend des
motoneiges ou qui arrivent dans un
secteur puis une montagne qu'ils aient
été envahis pendant toute une journée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la montagne est scrap d'une certaine
manière
et point la nana qui est ici pour voir
des traces de motoneige le ya plein
d'endroits québec pour voir sur une
enfant faire que si ça continue dans
cette voie l'eau dans dix ans dans 20
ans dans trente ans en europe au limon
vous conte aujourd'hui passer ça c'est
inévitable
on quitte pour la station wapishish cas
le point de départ de notre randonnée de
motoneige dans les monts groulx
selon le protocole d'entente adoptée par
québec
les motoneigistes doivent être
accompagnés par un guide pendant notre
visite
notre guide c'est pierre lavoie
l'important ça me prend des disciplines
encore partout parce qu'il ya des grands
comptes
je veux pas par son arrêt d'un quotidien
qui faisait trop grasse on sera mal ses
racines handicap à remonter en france de
la journée mon rôle l'hiver la motoneige
a commencé le quotidien
certaines religions
vous
on aperçoit notre part asie c'est
tellement plaisant mais récit d'un roulé
dans poudreuse 245 centime à damas bon
bien
la deuxième plus belle montagne au
canada dans les montagnes rocheuses la
colombie britannique
après s'être donné mon gros ici
[Musique]
ce que j'aime c'est la discipline des
gens en moto match conforme que demand
une petite famille on est à environ 25
guide chacun le petit groupe de 5,6 on
est des bonnes collection d'une dont
ceux par la radio on se protège
on a implanté une discipline une manière
de rouler à notre façon propre
environnement propre pour les skieurs
tessa à gauche
[Musique]
il ya un lien de partout c'est si elles
ferment québec la gaspésie beaucoup le
lac saint jean c'est ce qui a forcé le
l'environnement nous donner une
permission de venir c'est vraiment ils
retombent économique la contempler la
craie et motoneigistes du bien ici tu
dois partir de montréal ça écoute même
pièce par jour ceci très bon
l'économiste
les randonneurs à pied gaspillage
d'énergie
l'eia report one piece le dow a atteint
100 piasses l'europe une motoneige à
20000 puis le repos à 30 40 litres
d'essence par jour
les gones yam sûr camper dans mon temps
et je respecte ça c'est formidable faire
ce métier tu peux pas perdre chez sport
de se développer
on repart vers québec rencontré le
biologiste responsable du dossier au
ministère de l'environnement
la première chose qu'on veut lui
demander c'est la motoneige est ce que
c'est réellement dommageable
avaya plusieurs études le qui ont
autorisé à l'extérieur du québec qui
démontre que la motoneige peut avoir un
impact notamment sur les plantes
arctique alpine sur les hauts sommets
des membres ou parce qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de neige qui s'accumule en
raison des vents qui sont très forts il
peut avoir aussi un impact sur la faune
de comme par exemple quand il vous faut
récit est connu pour avoir s'éloigner
des sources de bruit le ministère
reconnaît qu'il peut y avoir des
conséquences alors pourquoi autoriser la
présence des motoneiges il y avait une
problématique grandissante d'utilisation
de la zone du sommet par des
motoneigistes qui allaitent façon
illégale
suite au constat qu'on a faits qui était
très difficile sinon impossible de
surveiller la totalité du territoire
était décidé de plutôt autorisé des
gains à respecter un protocole très
strict encadrement de façon à minimiser
les impacts ce que monsieur boisjoli
nous dit c'est qu'il y avait des
motoneigistes qui respectait pas
l'interdiction d'aller sur les sommets
comme québec n'avait pas les moyens de
faire respecter les règles on a décidé
d'encadrer plutôt que d'interdire la
réserve de biodiversité ou affiches qu'a
fait partie du réseau des aires
protégées du québec qui couvrira
prochainement près de 17 % du territoire
pour atteindre cette cible
internationale québec crée une trentaine
de désignation d'aires protégées avec
chacune leurs contraintes
dans certaines on peut chasser ou pêcher
dans d'autres québec devrait bientôt
permettre d'écoper forestière une aire
protégée
ça veut pas dire qu'on doit laisser
milieu à l'état sauvage
ce qui est curieux c'est ce qui a mis sa
d'environnement qui essaie d'avoir une
bonne figure en protégeant des
territoires parce qu'ils ont des quotas
à respecter comme une image de
protection d'environnement au niveau
international nos niveaux local
provincial du programme chose qui est
fait pour faire en sorte que ces
réserves de biodiversité l'eau soit
véritablement
protégeons
c'est très important de protéger son
demain si le protocole enlèverait de
négociations
faut voir on serait 50 motos des gens
des montagnes
il y aurait des traces partout il y
avait des arbres coupés partout tu
verrais des élastiques tueurs et des
couloirs s'est elle même l'odeur ci
s'est imposé
ce sport motorisé l'eau est incompatible
avec un sport non motorisés qui la
raquette et le ski 1 nuit à l'eau et pas
l'inversé les montagnes c'est à cinq
mille kilomètres carrés c'est grand le
la réserve si le tiers
on a toujours été d'accord avec le
développement de la motoneige dans le
monde
la seule chose qu'on préconise c'est que
ce développement alors se fasse à
l'extérieur la réserve de biodiversité
parler aux motoneigistes parler aux
randonneurs les deux vont vous
mentionner l'importance de préserver
c'est au niveau des moyens qui sont
repris qu'il ya des petites divergences
mais motivés par la protection pour
respecter nos objectifs internationaux
de protection
c'était un peu la course folle à la
désignation d'aires protégées dans les
derniers mois sur les monts groulx
le ministère ne dit qu'ils n'avaient pas
les moyens d'interdire la motoneige
donc il a encadré des compromis comme
celui là est ce qu'on a ne fait ailleurs
au québec pour atteindre nos cibles
je